there's something else that you need to
know about money
as time passes money will lose its value
because of something we call
inflation in 1913 a gallon of milk cost
around 36 cents
in 2013 the price rose to and fifty
three cents
nearly ten times as much most countries
aim for an inflation rate between two to
two point five percent
annually this number is how much value
the money you have stored up
loses every year meaning that saving all
your money in a bank account
actually becomes a problem over time and
that's when you're presented with this
term
investing the idea of using your money
to make more money to beat this rate of
inflation
you've probably heard about this stock
market thing and how it's one of the
easiest ways to invest your money but
what even is the stock market how do you
even begin investing it and is it truly
as lucrative as other people want you to
believe
the market's open again after the worst
week since the financial crisis the
funds the hedge funds jumping
200 points at the open this morning it's
just a good place to put your savings
you suddenly put them together and you
say damn it that's what's happening
a market is simply a place in which
things are bought
and sold if you live in a country like
the united kingdom the united states or
india your economy is very much
fueled on a wide array of markets for
example a fruit market deals with the
buying and selling of fruits
a real estate market deals with the
buying and selling of houses and the
stock market
deals with the buying and selling of
stocks which begs the question
what exactly are stocks a stock or a
share both terms are used
interchangeably to essentially mean the
same thing
represents a par ownership in a company
if company x
had a total of 10 shares sometimes
commonly referred to as the outstanding
shares
and the founder of this company owns all
10 shares
they own 100 of the company if the
founder owns
five shares then they own only 50 of the
company
and so on now we often refer to those
who own shares in a company as a
shareholder but this begs a new question
why would a business owner or
a founder decide to sell shares in their
own company
[Music]
imagine for a moment that you owned your
own company
a bakery things have been going well you
own the best baked goods in the area and
sometimes customers are queuing beyond
the door but you're aiming big
see you truly believe that your bakery
company and the goods that you produce
are the next best thing in the industry
and so you want to expand your business
you want to open up more chains hire
more
employees run bigger marketing campaigns
but to do that
you're gonna need to raise more capital
or money for your company
now you could go to the bank and ask to
borrow money but that means paying
interest on that loan they might even
deem you too
risky and refuse to accept your offer so
another option to raise capital for your
business
is by issuing or selling shares in your
company you can either do this
privately and sell those shares to some
good friends who believe in your
business
or you can do this publicly and have
those shares sold to anyone that wants
to buy
this would be done through a special
event which is known as an ipo
an initial public offering whereby your
private company
becomes a public company and so after
another successful day at the bakery
you decide to do it you decide to ipo in
frenzy on wall street today for the
initial public offering of twitter
board pricing its ipo at 19 each
electric car makers
surged nearly 41 the second best ipo
game of the year
tremendous interest in this ipo this
morning
uber has priced its ipo at 45
per share
part of going public as a company is
deciding on how many shares of your
company you would like to actually
issue and the number of shares you issue
to the public is commonly referred to as
the float
now the initial value of each share in
your company is determined by
how well your company is doing
financially how similar businesses are
doing and how much demand there will be
for your shares when they do go public
along with many other factors public
companies will then have their shares
listed on what is called a stock
exchange
to explain this let's use fruit markets
as an analogy
in your city there may be numerous
amounts of fruit markets
but you will have the choice of only one
of these fruit markets to set up
your fruit stall now instead of fruit
markets imagine they're called stock
exchanges
they're the actual place at which the
trading occurs and instead of fruit
stores
there are a bunch of companies listed at
these stock exchanges it's up to you
to pick the most appropriate exchange to
list your company's shares
and each stock exchange will have their
own specific requirements in order for
companies to have their shares
listed and traded there some of the
biggest exchanges in america
are the new york stock exchange founded
in 1817
the nasdaq founded in 1971 most notable
for having some of the biggest
tech companies listed there such as
google apple amazon and intel but stock
exchanges exist around the world
not just america now let's introduce
stock brokers into the mix
a stock broker purchases and sells
stocks on behalf of an
investor they act as a middleman in the
past brokers would go to what is called
a trading floor at a stock exchange
shouting over one another trying to
fulfill their clients requests
but thanks to the power of technology
this process has become
more and more automated and is done
using computer algorithms
this actually reduced the need for a
physical location for a stock exchange
the nasdaq for example has
no trading flaws at all so how does a
trade actually
happen an investor will first go to a
broker and make an
order for a share just like you'd make
an order for amazon
this order however will include a few
extra details in order to help
your broker first you must actually
specify the company in which you'd like
to buy
or sell shares in this is often
represented through what is called a
ticker symbol which is just an
abbreviated name to represent a company
apple's ticker symbol is
aapl amazon is amzn tesla is tsla
to name a few you can find out what a
company's ticker symbol is through a
quick
google search next is the side which is
do you want to buy or sell shares then
you have the type of order
you see it helps to see the stock market
as an auction market there are
thousands of buyers bidding for how much
they want to buy a share for and
thousands of people selling
asking for a certain price when a buyer
and seller match
the trade commences this happens
millions of times a day
as the price of a share fluctuates based
on the supply and demand for those
shares
one order type is a market order which
essentially tells your broker to buy or
sell that share at whatever price is
available on the market
another order type is a limit order
which like
an auction sets a reserve price for the
shares you want to sell
or a highest bid for the shares you want
to buy meaning you won't sell for
anything less than your reserve price
and you won't buy for anything more
expensive than your highest bid
of course the risk here being that if
the stock never hits the price you're
aiming for
then the order will never be filled now
there are other order types that exist
but
a market order and a limit order are
generally considered the big two
after providing your order type you then
let your broker know the quantity of the
shares you'd like to buy
and that's it in the past this would
have been done through written mail
buying and selling actual physical stock
certificates then once the telephone
came along you could place an order with
your broker over the phone
now however most brokerages are online
or have apps where you can
place an order without actually having
to speak to somebody and the shares have
moved from becoming physical
certificates to electronic records
much to the delight of any introverted
investor so
the question now is how do you the one
who is watching this video
use all of this knowledge to make the
right investment decision
but before we go on if you're gonna be
browsing online for
stocks then at least make sure that your
browser is secure which is where this
video's sponsor
is one that i've genuinely been looking
forward to it's nordvpn
so i've actually been using nordvpn for
a while now now i've got it set up on my
computer
on my phone on my tv i even have my
parents using it for those of you that
don't know what nordvpn is
i'll explain it real simple it's
essentially a virtual private network
provider so what it does is it protects
your identity online from potential
hackers or third parties
from accessing your online browsing
activity it'll basically take your
online data
and put it behind a safe wall of next
generation encryption
where not even your own internet service
providers can access it it's literally
as simple as
opening the software on your device and
hitting connect and that's it you're
secured
and here's a little secret that some of
you may or may not already be aware of
if you've ever encountered a website or
you're trying to stream a show or
something that isn't available in your
country
nordvpn actually allows you to change
the server that you're on in order to
access that website or that show for
example one of my favorite christopher
nolan films is interstellar which
actually isn't available on the uk
netflix
so if i then go into nordvpn and change
my server to france however
i can then watch it and it is available
for me to stream
plus nordvpn is offering a huge discount
on their two year plan if you go to
nordvpn.com forward slash james janney
or you can use the code james janney at
checkout and even better you get a 30
day money back guarantee along with a 24
7
customer support if you ever need help
or have any issues but
they are offering this discount for a
limited time so
do be sure to secure yourself online by
clicking the link in the description
below or go to
james
nordvpn.com
the game of investing has various
players you'll often hear people use the
term
retail investors or institutional
investors
a retail investor refers to people like
me or you who are making investments for
their own personal account
institutional investors however refers
to the big players in the game
pension funds mutual funds hedge funds
banks and so on that invest
large sums of money on behalf of their
clients these institutions will often
have analysts who meticulously study the
market and determine the best investment
decisions to make
this video is however focused for people
like me and you
retail investors the goal is to make
money and to do this we want to buy a
stock
and at some point sell it for a higher
price profiting the difference
you'll commonly hear the phrase buy low
sell high that is essentially what we're
aiming for but to do that
we're going to have to have an idea of
what stocks are going to rise in price
and what stocks are going to fall in
price but how could you possibly know
that well the price of a share is very
much
fueled by the supply and demand for that
share if tomorrow
apple releases some great news about an
upcoming product we'll expect demand in
apple shares to increase
as confidence in the company grows and
people expect apple to be more
profitable with the release of this
upcoming product
because of this sellers want to be paid
more for their shares
and buyers are willing to pay higher for
those shares the price of apple stock
therefore increases but this means there
is a lot of unpredictability in the
stock market
all sorts of things can impact the price
of a share a change in ceo
the quality of the products a new
government policy or even how
fashionable a given business sector is
it's difficult for the average retail
investor working a job or running a
business
to have to keep up with this every day
and this is why investing in the long
term
is generally considered better for the
average retail investor
than investing in the short term long
term investing is
buying shares and holding onto those
shares for potentially years down the
line billionaire investor warren buffett
is well known for applying the strategy
of value
investing where he looks over a
company's fundamentals the assets they
own their liabilities the actual book
value of the company and
invests in companies that he feels are
undervalued this has obviously worked
out incredibly well for him
short-term investing however usually
means holding on to shares for sometimes
even less than a day
before you sell them for most retail
traders however this is just
too risky too easy to lose money and not
worth the time
stress and energy required to
consistently be making a return on your
investments
most of us want to be able to make
investments that are passive
in other words they don't involve a lot
of time and energy required in order to
be maintaining them ideally we want to
be able to set it
and leave it and for some people even
the idea of doing research into a
company
seems like more effort than we'd like
enter
indexes indexes measure the performance
of certain stocks and tend to tell us
something about the stock market overall
for example you might have already heard
of the dow jones industrial average
sometimes shortened to the dow jones or
just the dow this
is an index that tracks the stock
performance of the top
30 companies listed on the stock
exchange in the united states
our fears that the dow will drop and
drop quickly
up more than 1000 points the dow sharply
higher
above 30 000 as you talked about perhaps
you might have heard of the standard and
pause 500
more commonly known as the s p 500 this
index
tracks the stock performance of the top
500 companies
listed on the us stock exchange in the
uk we have the ftse 100 which tracks the
top
100 uk companies listed on the exchange
the purpose of these indexes alone is to
help us see how the stock market is
doing overall but
what if you were able to invest into a
fund that contained all of these
companies inside of it
this is where index funds and what we
call etfs which stand for exchange
traded funds
come into play both of which are very
much the same with only slight
differences
for example the vanguard s p 500 etf
contains all of the companies inside the
s p 500 index
but allows you to invest in it just like
you would a normal stock
in other words you can go to your broker
and make the purchase of one share in
the vanguard s p 500
etf meaning that you are essentially
splitting up your money into the 500
companies that the s
p 500 index tracks this single fund
acts as a way of diversifying your
investments without actually having to
go out of your way to invest and manage
shares in 500 different companies
instead an etf like the vanguard s p 500
does this for you it looks as though
you're invested in just one stock
but in fact it's a basket of other
stocks best of all when a new company
enters the s p
500 index it is automatically included
in the s p
500 etf without you needing to do
anything
you'll often hear many personal finance
writers or youtubers preach about
investing in etfs like the s p
500 because it's a comparatively safe
and passive investment if you are
looking to invest in the long term
but the question is how much can you
reasonably expect to earn from the stock
market
truth is we've been in a bull market
since
a bull market is generally where we see
the prices and shares rise
as opposed to a bear market where in
which we see the prices and shares
fall because of that we're seeing more
and more investors expect
higher than average returns on their
portfolio which is just a fancy way of
saying the stocks that they own but
market crashes as we know
are bound to happen and often for
reasons that we can't predict in most
cases
you'll find that an average annual
return of six to ten percent of your
investments
is good which of course doesn't sound as
flashy or as extravagant as one might
expect
but remember for the average retail
investor the stock market shouldn't be
seen as a way of making a lot of money
fast
for the long term investor it's very
much a game of patience and investing in
your portfolio
month by month but be warned you will
encounter people promising you high
returns on your money
all over the place and with the rise in
popularity of apps like
robin hood or weeble and others that
make trading in the stock market
more and more easily accessible retail
investors often invest into the stock
market without doing their due diligence
or a slither of research
so here's some key warnings to be on the
lookout for you'll often hear the phrase
by the dip and as annoying as it is to
hear that it's important to understand
investing can very much be fueled by our
emotions
and when we see a stock rise in price
the fear of missing out may kick in
and we may end up making a bad trade
it's in fact when we see a share fall in
price that it's usually the best time to
invest
the dip is where the money is made two
invest what you can afford to lose a
common piece of advice you'll hear is to
invest roughly 10
of your earnings each month for me that
often ends up being put into the
vanguard
s p 500 etf that we mentioned before but
it's money that i'm happy to set
and leave for a very long time we're
talking 10 to 20 years into the future
three don't panic and sell the moment
you see your shares fall in value
if you're investing for the long term
then you should expect to see
some peaks and troughs but if your
portfolio is diversified enough
this shouldn't matter in the long run
you never lose money on a trade until
you've actually sold the shares that
you've bought
for those of you wondering i have a
brokerage account opened with
vanguard and i also have a trading 212
account which is a trading app here in
the uk
the us equivalents being apps like
robinhood weibull
td ameritrade honestly finding a good
broker for where you live
is as easy as a simple google search on
a subject
of course if you are going to be
browsing online then do be sure to check
out nordvpn's huge discount
the link for that will be in the
description below or you can go to
nordvpn.com forward slash james janney
or just use the code
james janney at checkout now i know i
didn't get to talk about things like
short selling options trading or what a
market maker is and so on and so forth
this video is very much more about
grounding your understanding in the
stock market i've always found that
if you understand the core of a subject
well then you can usually
understand the intricacies around that
subject much better and this video is
really something that i wish i had when
i was
first starting to look into the stock
market that being said if you did enjoy
the video do hit the like button do
subscribe those things are completely
for free but they help out a ton
my friends i wish you the best rest of
the day
as always hand to head salute
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you